hey youtubers is Charlie really awesome
news today is like the day that Marvel
decided to remind you that it's making
two really awesome movies right now so
we had some Thor stuff earlier today now
we have some spider-man stuff so I'm
gonna play these clips and then I'm
gonna explain what's going on this is
what it's like filming in the batter
oh it's raining cats and dogs
spider-man homecoming is shooting on the
same stage the guardians of the galaxy
shot on that's where this image came
from so as they were rolling out
shutting down production spider-man was
rolling in
so I told he want to find out what's on
the mixtape that James Gunn gave him but
now he's posting pictures of himself in
the costume behind the scenes there were
some pictures that paparazzi got the
other day of him doing outdoor scenes in
the spider-man costume now wasn't
necessarily anything spoilery but it
just it confirmed that he was wearing
the costume from Civil War which I feel
like we all assumed he was going to the
cool thing about this picture is that
you get a much better close-up of the
stark tech web-shooters obviously they
do a couple other things too they have
the spider light there's probably some
digital readouts some communication
devices really anything that spider-man
might need in the field kind of like a
Swiss Army tool and Tony Stark's
presence in the felt like we haven't
seen Robert Downey jr. on this set he's
only gonna be in part of the film not as
much as you would think he is but he's
still gonna be a very important part
probably offer spider-man a mixture of
technical advice technical help like
here's some really cool new toys that
will help you fight this villain and
he'll fill that Uncle Ben role like when
Spiderman has like this crisis of
conscience where he's like I'm not sure
what I was supposed to do how am I
supposed to deal with this situation and
he can't talk to Aunt May about it
because he's still trying to keep his
secret from her so Tony Stark is like
the go-to or he's like listen kid here's
my advice for you you can imagine what
kind of advice Tony Stark would give to
spider-man like he's one of the best
characters in the Marvel Universe
that's seeming like he's not taking
anything seriously while he's taking
like a thousand different things really
seriously inside his head all at the
same time that's usually what leads to
his downfall but that's not necessarily
a spider-man problem this is his first
film so we'll really just see him
getting a taste of the superhero life
trying to deal with like 10 different
things and high school problems at the
same time that's one of the cool things
about this film is that we've learned
about a bunch of people that are being
cast around his high school we've
actually seen pictures of the high
school itself so whereas most of the
previous spider-man films when they're
at the high school only deal with bully
situations like the end of the Flash
Thompson fight they did that in both the
Andrew Garfield spider-man
the tobey maguire spider-man I think
there's gonna be a lot more of that to
balance out the film because he's only
like 15 16 years old I think he's 16
when the movie picks up so like the
typical high school joke is is that like
your average high school student treats
regular high school problems is
the biggest thing in the world
so spider-man has all that going on in
actual biggest problems in the world
going on with like real supervillains
trying to do really terrible things so I
would expect a lot more high school
comedy less trophy characters like less
of that Flash Thompson type stuff going
on my Flash Thompson might still be in
the movie this is the actual high school
bully of the film so I would expect him
to be portrayed in a more well-rounded
way like he won't just be a caricature
for Peter Parker to take down so like if
you guys haven't seen anti-bullying has
been a big campaign in the last couple
years I wouldn't be surprised if they
present like the solution to Peter
Parker dealing with his bully has a
mirror to the way he deals with the
supervillain bully played by Michael
Keaton who I think we all believe is the
vulture there's still a couple
characters he could be but even the
trades are like we think he's the
vulture but don't expect Marvel to
comment or confirm on that they don't
they don't really confirm on spoilers
like that but you know that typically
like the arc you would see in a movie
like this is that Peter Parker's in high
school just you know trying to be a
normal kid then he gets into a superhero
situation tries to do some good gets his
ass handed to him learns a lesson get
some help from Tony Stark defeats the
villain and then circle of life he goes
back to high school
after he's defeated the super villain
and uses the lesson that he's learned to
deal with the bully at school so they'll
be filming the movie for a while longer
I'm expecting them to come to comic-con
briefly but I don't know if they're
gonna show any footage off guardians of
the galaxy is the only Marvel panel that
they've announced what they'll probably
do typically they don't announce
everything they're gonna do because they
don't know who they're gonna bring it
it's really last-minute for them
so like the guardians of the galaxy
panel will be the main attraction
then they'll piggyback a couple other
movies on that so expect some dr.
strange just because that movies coming
out so soon and expects some spider-man
Sony's largely footing the bill for
spider-man but I think that Marvel is
gonna do everything it can to help
market the film so that would include a
special appearance by spider-man at
their big Marvel comic con panel so do
not be surprised if Tom Holland makes a
special appearance
but I'll totally do like a spider-man
Comic Con video if they actually
announce something that they're bringing
it's just that I'm not expecting them to
show off footage this early well let me
know in the comments what kind of
behind-the-scenes teasers like this do
you want to keep seeing from the film
like do you like it that they're letting
them post up I think is actually pretty
cool a couple of years ago they probably
wouldn't wanted the actors to do this
they're just like studios aren't
comfortable with social media in general
but I think as they start to figure it
out they're a little bit cooler about
letting the actors interact with fans so
they're like hey look you know we're
doing really awesome stuff without
necessarily spoiling the film so I would
just expect this to continue on all the
Marvel films like I just did that Thor
video earlier today they just started
shooting that this week and because all
those actors have amazingly huge
social-media followings I think they're
gonna try and do as much from behind the
scenes as possible like they're even
doing the joke with Thor's hammer on the
toilet which is an oldie but a goodie
they actually posted this like right
after I posted my video I was like ah
nuts I could've put that in my video but
here it is in all its glory so high
fives all around for Marvel being really
cool with letting its actors post stuff
from behind the scenes what's gonna
happen next is I'll probably do a video
for the Doctor Strange prequel comic
it's a prequel for the movie it explains
what's going on with Wong's character
what's going on with Maz Mickelson's
villain character he's the main villain
of the film even though there's gonna be
a lot of really trippy cosmic stuff
going on too so be sure to subscribe to
get that and if there's any other comic
book videos that you guys want me to do
this weekend just let me know in the
comments ooh and I almost forgot I was
gonna tell the story of how Thor called
Marvel's corporate version of Odin to
try and get Spider Man in Civil War so
what was happening is is before they
were getting ready to cast spider-man
earlier they were getting ready to start
doing that Tom Holland was shooting
another movie with Chris Hemsworth at
the time so he asked him knowing that
he's Thor he's like hey man can you put
in a good word for me so he called the
president of the studio Kevin Feige boss
like Kevin Feige is the guy that is in
charge of all the Marvel movies but he
has a boss in that boss has a boss too
so every boss has a boss but Chris
Hemsworth called Kevin Feige as boss to
put in a good word for Tom Holland so
that definitely helped but then on top
of that when he went to the audition Tom
Holland was talking to the Russos and he
was like hey you know I'm actually
pretty acrobatic I can do back flow
so I can do some spider-man moves should
I do that in my audition and typically
people are like no no do not try and
kill yourself in this audition this is
more of an acting thing you don't need
to do backflips we have some people for
that but the really funny thing is that
the Russos who are just like a couple of
awesome comic-book geeks themselves were
like totally go for it do a backflip
during your audition
so Tom Holland when he was done giving
the line readings that they asked for
did the back flip nailed the audition
and he got it in the rest is history
so just a really funny story about how
Tom Holland got his foot in the door and
then nailed the audition with the help
of the Russos so why you guys wait for
my next video you can click here to
learn all about how Marvel is kind of
taken over spider-man for Sony even
though it's got Sony's name on it it's
still like a Marvel film and you can
click here for my Thor teaser video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you